testing testing. Okay. All right. Hello, everyone. Thank you for coming to the final
recitation session of the semester. I'm Matt. I'm one of the CAs for the course course.
And today we'll be talking about some practice problems for the final section of the course.
So just first off, so you're aware. See, we're recording this for posting on Piazza later
just so you know. So yeah, just recording notice. And overall, the point of today's session will
be to go over some of the sample problems that were handed out or suggested by the professors
in various sections throughout the various course lectures. So as a reminder, the final exam
will focus on the material from section three. So it's not a overall comprehensive exam. It's
just focused on final section of the course section three. The problems that we'll talk about
today are all from the Russell and Norbig textbook. And they all come from the aimacode.github.io website
that's been I think shared a couple times throughout the course. So overall, let's begin.
We'll start with an easy problem as a warm up. The first question, this is 13.1. It says,
show from first principles that the probability of A given B intersect A equals one.
So does anyone have any ideas on how you would approach solving this?
Okay. That's a definition of conditional probability. Yes, that's a great way to start.
So to start using the definition of the conditional probability, probability of A given B intersect A
would be probability of A intersect B intersect A divided by probability of B intersect A.
And so this should be the part where it's very clear. What would this expression reduce to
this one right here? Well, if you take A intersect B intersect A, this has already been intersected
with A. So intersecting a second time will really do anything. So the result of that would still be
equivalent to B intersect A. And so then if you just have probability of B intersect A over
probability B intersect A, the answer will always be one, no matter what. Which of course intuitively
makes sense. I mean, if you're conditioning on B intersect A, it means that it's a given that A
is true. So the probability that A is true given that A is true should be one always. Okay,
but that's just a warm up problem. Let's do some more counting oriented problems. So this is a
a problem about poker. So it says consider the set of all possible five card poker hands dealt
fairly from a standard deck of 52 cards. So when it says it's dealt fairly, that means all cards are
perfectly shuffled. They're shuffled randomly. Yes. Yes.
Oh, let's see. There's not really a whiteboard in here.
Yeah, I mean, you could. I think I think they're writing it would be easier, but it's just a way
to represent the idea. Yeah. Like you're saying, if you had A intersect B and you intersected it
with A, it would be the same because you'd already be in A. But yeah, I see what you're saying.
Yeah. Okay. So five card poker hands. How many atomic events are there in the joint
probability distribution? How many five card hands are there? So if you recall combinatorics,
counting any, any ideas, what the, yes, what?
Lose, but when you have a poker hand, the ordering that you draw the cards and doesn't really matter
or not times five factorial, but divided by five factorial, right? So it would be 52,
choose five, which is exactly what you said, 52 times 51 times 50 times 49 times 48,
divided by five factorial. Because intuitively, you start by having five choices and you choose
your five cards, first having 52 choices, then 51 and 50, then 49 and 48. But then because the
ordering that you draw them, it doesn't really matter. IE, your hand is equivalent,
regardless of the order you draw them. That's why you would need to divide by five factorial,
because that's the number of equivalent ways to draw the same hand. Now the second question,
what is the probability of each atomic event of each hand? Well, it's pretty easy. It's just one
divided by that number we just computed. So it's one over 2,598,960. Okay. So that's fairly simple.
Next question, what is the probability of being dealt a royal straight flush? Well, again,
this is a counting problem. So how many royal straight flushes exist? There's only four,
one for each of the four suits. So you would have four over 2 million that number.
And then the final question is how many ways can you get what's the probability of getting four of a
kind? And so this one's a bit trickier to count. So there are 13 numbers or 13 types of cards from
Ace to King. And so there would be 13 types of four of a kind that you could get. And then after
you've drawn your four of a kind, you would still have one more card in your hand to draw. And there
would be 48 possible options for the last card in your hand. So then you would have 13 types of
four of a kind times 48. And that would give you, if you reduce it, one over 4,165 possible ways to
do four of a kind. So yeah, these are all counting problems, you know, probability, a lot of the
time boils down to counting the number of possible ways to do a thing and counting the number of
overall options in the universe. So yeah, okay. Now, how about a question about coin flips? This
is number 13.17. It says, suppose you are given a coin that lands heads with probability x and
tails with probability 1 minus x. So it's not necessarily a balanced coin. It might be a biased
coin that might be weighted one way or the other towards a certain side. And it says, are the outcomes
of successive flips of the coin independent of each other given that you know the value of x?
And then are the outcomes independent if you do not know the value of x?
So what are people's thoughts on the first question? If you know the value of x would all of the
coin flips be independent of each other? Yes, indeed, they would be independent of each other.
But what do you think about the second one? If you don't know the value of x, are they independent
of each other? They actually aren't independent of each other. Because as you flip the coin more
times, you learn more about what the value of x might be. And so that changes your prediction of
what future events are more likely to be. So overall, for the case where you know x, it's very
easy to calculate that they're independent. This is just the formula for independence, probably
of f1 equals heads, probably. And the joint of f1 being heads and f2 being heads given x is just
x times x, which is also equal to the probability of f1 equals heads given x times probably f2 equals
heads given x. So since these two things are equal, the joint distribution is the product of the
marginal distributions, that means the two are independent. But in the case of when x is not known,
it's basically like successive flips, you update your belief of what x's value is. And so they're
no longer independent of each other. So yeah. All right. It's a tricky question, for sure.
All right. So going from one coin to a bag of coins, this is question 14.1, say we have a bag of
three biased coins, a, b and c, with probabilities of coming up heads 20%, 60%, and 80% respectively.
One coin is drawn randomly from the bag with equal likelihood of drawing each of the three coins,
and then the coin is flipped three times to generate three outcomes, call them x1, x2, x3.
Question one is draw the Bayesian network corresponding to this setup and define the necessary
conditional probability tables. Then question two, calculate which coin was most likely to have been
drawn from the bag if the observed flips come out heads twice and tails once. So first off, can anyone
say what the describe what the Bayesian network for this would look like?
It looks like you do three, or you do four different things in this process.
You first you pick a coin, you draw a coin from a bag, and then you do three random coin flips.
So you'll have a network with four things on it. And I think here I'll show you. It would look
like this. Your first action would be drawing the coin. And so the coin has the random probabilities
here where there are the three possible coins you can draw each with probability one-third.
And then you have the three separate coin flips that are given the coin that you drew,
the conditional probability of getting heads on each of these coin flips depends on the coin
that you drew from the bag. So if you had coin A, that said 20% heads, coin B is 60% heads,
coin C is 80% heads. So then you have the three coin flips, X1, X2, X3. And this is how you could, yes.
So it's just a way of representing your random variables and how they interact with each other.
So this is just just a representation of that. Yeah, the variables could be, however you,
they could be continuous variables. They could be not even discrete. They could be like
Gaussian distribution. And then you could have the downstream variables could be dependent on
whatever value that that continuous value has. And you could have variables that are conditioned on
continuous values as opposed to being conditioned on discrete values. In this case, they're all discrete
examples though. So yeah. Okay, so then the second question says calculate which coin was most
likely to have been drawn from the bag if the observed flips come up heads twice and tails once.
Just as a guess, does anyone want to guess which coin is probably the most likely?
Yeah, C says probability 80%. So personally, I would think it might be B because B is 60%
and it came up 66.66666 of the time it came up with heads. So that would make it me think that
B is probably the most likely one. But we can test that mathematically. So overall,
so does anyone have a guess on what would be a good way to test this mathematically?
Well, wind and doubt, Bayes rule is usually a good thing to go with. So we want to calculate
essentially given two heads in one tail. We want to know what is the probability distribution of
the three coins or what's the likelihood of the three coins given that observation. So we can
instead rephrase this as find C with the greatest posterior probability. So probability of C given
two heads one tail. And so now we have probability of C given two heads one tail. Using Bayes rule,
we can invert that and we say through Bayes rule, probability of C given two heads one tail equals
probability two heads one tail given C times probability of C divided by probability of two heads
in one tail. But now at this point, we can actually start making things easier because we don't
actually care exactly what the right probability is. We only were asked to determine which coin was
the most likely. So for one thing, this term probably two heads one tail. That's the overall
probability. It's not conditioned on the coin. And so that's a constant. And that's a constant we can
just essentially factor out and now say that probably of C given two heads one tail is proportional
to probability two heads one tails given C times probability of C. And again, probability of C was
one third for all three coins because we said that they were all equally likely. So that's another
term that we can just factor out. So overall, we can say that the probability of C given two heads
one tail is actually proportional to the probability of two heads one tail given C. So now we just
have to find which coin gives the highest value for that term and that will tell us which coin was
the most likely one. So this is something we can compute directly. So probably x1 equals tails,
x2 equals heads, x3 equals heads given coin A. Well, those three flips are independent of each other.
So we can separate this into the three subterms multiplicatively. And then we know from our
tables that for A, it's a 20% chance of being heads and an 80% chance of being tails. So we would
have 0.8 times 0.2 times 0.2. So 0.032. So this does not tell us the exact probability of C given
two heads two tails. But we know that it's proportional to this number. And then we can do the
same thing and compute that for the other two coins. So for coin B, we get 0.432. And for coin C,
we get 0.384. So from this, we can see that given we got two heads one tail, the least likely coin
is A by a significant margin. And then the other two coins are a lot closer to each other. So coin C
is fairly close. But with a 0.384 versus 0.432, this shows that the second coin, coin B,
is the one that was most likely to have generated the sequence of flips that we observed.
So does this make sense? Do you guys have any questions on this?
Okay, then we can move along. All right, then we'll do another problem with Bayesian networks.
This is problem 14.5, the museum alarm problem. So it says consider the Bayesian burglary network
where the museum alarm can be activated by a burglar or by an earthquake. And so they give you
this network that shows the conditional distribution of all these variables. So there's a small
likelihood 0.001 that a burglary might happen at this museum. And there's a 0.002 chance
that there might be an earthquake at this museum. And then both of those variables could
influence the likelihood of an alarm being triggered. So there's a 95% chance of the alarm
triggering if both events occur. A 94% chance if only the burglar happens. And a 0.99% chance
if a earthquake happens and a small 0.001% chance of a false alarm if neither of these events
are occurring. And then beyond that, there are two additional variables. Say there are two
night guards at the museum. One named John and one named Mary and each of them may call the police
if they hear the alarm go off. So given this Bayesian network, we have a couple questions we want
to look at. First one, if no evidence is observed, are burglary and earthquake independent?
Prove this from the numerical semantics and from the topological semantics. So looking at the
network, can we conclude that if we have no observations that burglary and earthquake are
independent of each other? Anyone want to guess?
Yes. Yes. They are definitely independent of each other. So we can see that they're not
conditioned on each other. They don't have a shared parent. So they are definitely independent
of each other from the topology of the graph. We can see that. But we can also prove this numerically.
So from the numerical semantics, if you were going to break this down and write out the
probabilities for everything, the probability, the joint probability of the burglary and the
earthquake, that could be equal to the joint probability of everything put together,
summed over all of the other variables that we don't care about. So the alarm, John and Mary
calls you sum over a, j and m, all of the options for those variables. And then, well, that joint
distribution, we can decompose it based on what we know about the conditional probabilities. So
the probability of b just becomes b by itself because it's not conditioned on anything else.
And it's the same thing goes for e. And then the probability of a is conditioned on b and e.
And then j is conditioned on a. And so is m, conditioned on a. And then moreover,
now that we have this broken out, these terms right here, these two have no dependence on a,
j and m. So they can pop out to the front outside of the summation. So then that leaves us these terms
on the inside. And then we can break these down further since this term doesn't depend on j.
And this term only depends on j. And this one depends on m. So you'd have the summation of j
over the options for j of j given a, the alarm status, and summation of m over m given a.
And thankfully, fortunately, due to the properties of probability distributions,
all of this, this will just sum to one because when you sum over all the options for
probability distribution, it will always sum to one. So this term will just go away.
This term will just go away. And then this term here will also just go away because it will
also be summing over a probability distribution that just sums to one. So in the end,
all of those things will just factor out. And you'll be left with the probability of b comma e
is equal to the probability of b times the probability of e, which again, this is the definition of
independence of variables. So right there, we've shown that numerically, you can show that they're
independent of each other, given the, using the sum going constraint for distribution,
yeah, okay, top. And topologically, e is independent of its non-descendants,
eb, given its parents, which is the empty set. So b and e are absolutely independent.
Okay, so now the second question. And this, I think, is a fairly important one to think about
with the Bayesian networks. If we observe that the alarm is true, our burglary and earthquake
independent. Justify your answer by calculating whether the probabilities involved
satisfy the definition of conditional independence. So thinking back to the lectures on
Bayesian networks, once you have observed that the alarm is true, our burglary and earthquake
still independent. Yes, you got it. They're not in, they are no longer independent.
The fact that you've observed the alarm now kind of links these two parent variables together
and they're now dependent on each other. So, and we can even show that mathematically by
breaking down all of the math. I mean, it's a lot of math to break down by hand, but you know,
what you would want to show, if you were going to show that they were independent,
you would want to show that probability of b comma e given a is equal to probability of b given a
times probability of e given a. This would be true if they're independent, but we'll see that
they're not, but we can compute the left side probability of e given a. We can use Bayes rule again
to reverse this and we'll have a normalizing term alpha that again has all of these values,
and you can, you can do all the math here and break it down and you can compute all of this,
but in the end, what you get at the end is that the left side probability of b comma e given a
would be this value, and then the product of these two sides would give you a completely
different value, and therefore, this shows that b and e are not conditionally independent given a.
So, does that make sense to everyone? Cool. All right. Okay, then let's move on from chapter 14
and go to chapter 16. This is problem 16.6, which is about the surprise candy company,
and they say the surprise candy company makes candy in two flavors.
75% are strawberry flavor and 25% are anchovy flavor. Each new piece of candy starts out with a
round shape, and as it moves along the product line, machine randomly selects a certain
percentage to be trimmed into a square, then each piece is wrapped in a paper wrapper, or sorry,
in a wrapper whose color is chosen randomly either red or brown. 70% of the strawberry candies are
round and 70% have red wrappers, while 90% of the anchovy candies are square and 90% have brown
wrappers. All candies are sold individually in sealed identical black boxes, where you can't,
you basically, when the box is sealed, you can't see the wrapper, you can't see the candy shape,
and so the idea is that, you know, when you open the box, that will give you more information about
what the candy might be, but you wouldn't know exactly what the flavor is until you actually eat it.
But now it says, now you the customer have just bought a surprise candy at the store,
but have not opened the box yet. So to start with, they ask, given these three networks,
these three Bayesian networks, which networks can correctly represent the probability distribution,
the joint probability distribution of the flavor wrapper in the shape. Which of these would you
oh yeah, and then oh sorry, second question, which is the best representation for this problem?
So intuitively, what anyone have any preference or inclination between these?
Okay, well, going off of the story, it said that they said they made in strawberry or anchovy flavor,
and then later they say strawberry candies have a certain probability distribution based on
70% round, 70% red, 90% square, 90% brown. So intuitively, the third option is the one that most
closely matches the story. However, the second option, number two, because it's a fully connected
network, technically you could use it to represent any problem, like just any problem. You could
rearrange the variables in some way that you could fit it to work with that network. However,
the third one, it matches the story better, so it's probably the best one to work with in this
context. And then finally, the first one actually can't represent the problem, because its structure
implies that the wrapper color and shape are marginally independent, which is not true. So in other
words, number one, doesn't work, number two, could work, but it's probably suboptimal, and number
three is probably the best one given the arrangement of variables that we've talked about in the
story so far. Yes. Number two said it fits it fully connected. Yes. Yeah, so I mean, because of
a base rule, you could always invert the probabilities, right? So if one thing is certain distribution
based on another thing, you could invert it and have it be the other way. So technically, you could,
even though we talked about flavor first, you could think of it as being in the opposite order
if you wanted to. But in this case, it'll be easiest if we do number three, because it'll be closer
to the original story. Okay. So then they said number three does network one assert that
probability of wrapper given shape, people's probably wrapper i.e. probably wrapper does not depend
on shape. Yes, it implies that from the structure of the graph, which is again, not true. We know
it's not true. So it doesn't work for this problem. And then the next question says, what is the
probability that your candy has a red wrapper? Okay. So this is a fairly easy problem to answer.
You just have to break it down into its subparts. So once we know the flavor, we know the probability
that's wrapper will be rather brown. So we can just marginalize the flavor out i.e. some over
the flavor options is what they mean by that. So the probably that the wrapper is red would be equal
to summing over all options of f. The probability that the wrapper is red and the flavor is f. So then
you could do the conditional probability from the joint. So this would be the probability that the
flavor is f times the probability that the wrapper is red given that the flavor is f. And from the
problem, we know that they said what they said 75% are strawberry and 70% of strawberry are red and
25% are anchovy and they said 10% or 90% of anchovier browns, so 10% would be red. So overall
you would have 75 times 0.7 plus 0.25 times 0.1 and so it would come out to 0.55. It would be the
overall chance of having a red wrapper. Okay. All right, so next question. This one I think is a
little bit harder. In the box, so suppose you open the box and now you observe that you have a
round candy with a red wrapper. Now what is the probability that it is a strawberry flavored candy?
So this one is now going from the initial problem where we had no information and about what the
candy looked like. And now we've opened the box and we get to update our information and that
gives us some additional clues about what we think are our probability of the candy is. So to start,
we could compute the two joint distributions for the two flavors or the joint probabilities for
the two flavors. So we get to start by saying the probability that the flavor equals strawberry
and the shape is round and the wrapper is red. Well, that would be the probability that the flavor
is strawberry times the probability the shape is round given the flavor is strawberry and the
probability that the wrapper is red given the flavor is strawberry. And all three of these are terms
that we have from the original story. So this is very easy to compute. So we had 0.75, 0.7, 0.7. We
get 0.3675. And it's very easy to compute this with the numbers that we had from the original
story. And then in addition to that, we would need to compute the probability that the flavor is
anchovy and the shape is round and the wrapper is red. So again, same thing except we swap out this
one term. And again, these are numbers basically more or less that we have from the original story.
So you'd have 0.25 times 0.1 times 0.1, so 0.2, 0.0025. So obviously, one thing to point out here
is that this number and this number, when you add them together, they don't sum to one. So why is that?
Exactly. That's exactly right. This is only looking at two options. The joint options of
flavors strawberry and these things and flavors anchovy and these things. So these are not the
conditional probabilities. These are the overall joint probabilities. But if we wanted to then get
from these numbers to the actual conditional probability numbers, where we would want to know
what's the probability flavor equals strawberry given shape is round, wrapper is red, what would we
have to do? All you have to do is normalize. So all you have to do is normalize. These are the
two options basically. Either the shape is strawberry or anchovy. We know that the other things
the wrapper is red and the shape is red. So all you have to do is add these two numbers together.
So that would give you 0.37 and that becomes your normalization term. So if you then divide 0.3675
divided by 0.37, then you've normalized and then you have your conditional probability distribution
which tells you that the probability that your flavor is strawberry given the shape is round
and the wrapper is red is actually 0.9932. So very high probability of having a strawberry candy
at this point. Although if you think originally all we knew was that 75% of candies were strawberry.
But now that we've observed the candy and we've seen the wrapper, we can now update our prior
posterior to know that there's a 99% chance above a 99% chance that it's strawberry.
So I think there's one more question here. Okay and this last one says an unwrapped strawberry
candy is worth S dollars on the open market and an unwrapped anchovy candy is worth A dollars.
Write an expression for the value of an unopened candy box. Does anyone have any inclination on this?
Just one, just one. It's an individually boxed candy.
Yep, yep. So at first it might seem like this is a harder question to answer but actually because
you don't know anything, you only know the box. You haven't opened it. All you have to go off of
is 0.75 or strawberry and 0.25 or anchovy. And so you just multiply those by the values to get
the overall expected value of the candy. All right. Okay, let's see. All right, moving on to section
17, 17.19 rock paper scissors, fire water. This says given in the children's game, rock paper
scissors, each player reveals at the same time a choice, rock paper or scissors, paper beats rock,
rock beats scissors, scissors beats paper. Now we'll propose an extended version where we add two
more options, fire and water, fire beats rock paper and scissors, rock paper and scissors,
beat water and water beats fire. So write out the payoff matrix and find a mixed strategy solution
to this game. Okay, so to start with, this is what the payoff matrix looks like. So we'll say that
player, we'll call the two players, players A and B and we'll say that there is player A's move
is denoted on the row and player B's move is denoted on the column. And so then we see that, you know,
if both players play rock, if both players get 0, 0, that's a tie. If player A plays rock and
player B plays paper, paper wins, that's a minus one for player A and a plus one for player B.
And so on the scissors and fire and water and these extra things that have been added to the game.
But overall, just a breakdown of who wins and who loses under which combination of plays.
So then the second question asks, what's a strategy or how do you propose a strategy for this game?
So we'll propose a mixed strategy for A where we'll pick probabilities for playing each of the
different actions. So a little R for playing rock, a little P for playing paper, a little S for
playing scissors and so on. And moreover, since these are probabilities, the five of them would have
to sum to one. Then the payoff for A based on B's possible options are as follows. So if player B plays
rock, then player A would have a plus one if on the P chance that they play paper, which would be a
win. They'd have a minus S for losing if they played scissors. They'd have a plus F for if they
won with playing fire and they'd have a minus W if they lost playing water and they'd have essentially
a zero if they threw rock as well. And so this is just the breakdown for each of the options of
what B could play. And they say it's easy to see that no option is dominant over the whole region.
So what they say is solving for the intersection of hyperplanes. Essentially, if you make these
into hyperplanes and solve for their intersect, you would solve for it and you would get
RPS equals 1 over 9 and F equals W equals 1 over 3. And by symmetry, if you did the same thing
with B, you would get the same result. So all right. Okay. So that's I think that's the only
question from problem section 17. But now I think the next couple are about neural networks. So one second.
Okay. So this is a fun problem. A fairly important problem actually.
It says 18.24 constructed by hand, a neural network that computes the ZOR function of two inputs.
Make sure to specify what sorts of units you are using. And just for a reminder, or if you're
not familiar with it, ZOR is the exclusive OR function that's basically given two inputs A and B.
It will return true if and only if exactly one of A is true. Otherwise, if A and B are both true,
it will return zero or return false. And if B and A are both false, it will also return false.
And then another question to ask here is, is this a problem that can be solved with a single
layer perceptron? Okay. You know the answer to this. Okay. So this is what the network looks like.
I guess if people wanted to discuss ideas of how to make this work, because I don't know
people want to, we'll just go the network and look at it. So to do this, you'll need to define
some sort of threshold function. So we'll just say we have this threshold T and the T has a
parameter X. And so if we have T equals X and you have an input that's a value Y or whatever,
if Y is greater than X, you would return one. But if Y is less than X, you would return zero.
So you have a nonlinear activation function right here in the terms in the form of a thresholding
function. So then using this thresholding function, we can implement ZOR using this network.
However, this is a two layer neural network. And importantly, you cannot implement ZOR with a one
layer perceptron. It's impossible. And that was a very important mathematical result back in the
1960s when perceptrons were first introduced, because that helped to show that single layer networks
were intrinsically limited in the kinds of functions they could represent. But by adding multiple
layers, you could represent more complex functions. But overall, this is what the working ZOR
neural network looks like. And we can also test it to verify that it does correctly implement
the ZOR function. So for example, if A and B are both zero, well, we have our neural network,
and we have these weights on each of the edges. So on each of these weights, you would multiply by
the weight value. But because it's all zeros, you would wind up with a zero here. And then there's
a threshold here, but it would be zero. So it'd be zero here. This 0.3 times zero would be zero,
zero, zero, zero, zero, zero point, negative, zero point, six times zero, zero. It's just zeros
all over. And so the output is zero. So that's good. And then if you instead had one of the inputs
to be one, then on this top branch, we would have one times zero point three. So you'd have a zero
point three here. You have a one times zero point three here. So you have a zero point three here.
And this is too small. It's less than zero point five. So it doesn't activate the threshold here.
So this is a zero, a zero times negative zero point six. And in the end, you have so you have zero,
zero, zero, zero point three. These three terms sum to zero point three. They're input to the
this threshold now, but zero point three is high enough to beat this is your point two threshold.
So we get one. So that's good. So that's one other part of the ZOR that's working correctly.
And then I think it's pretty obvious that if you flip to this, if you had a equals zero,
be equals one, you would get the exact same thing. I think it's pretty obvious.
But the last thing to see is if you now make a and b both equal to one, will it do the ZOR thing
and return zero? So in this case, you have a one times zero point three that gets passed along
on the top branch. And the one times zero point three gets passed along on the top branch.
But then here in the middle branch, the whole point of this extra layer here in the middle is
to essentially make make the ZOR effect happen. So you have a 0.3 coming from here from one times
0.3 and a one times your point three, you get a 0.6, which is enough to beat the threshold.
You get a one out one times negative 0.6 gives you negative 0.6 here. So these terms now cancel out
and the input to the final threshold is zero. And then the output is zero. And overall,
it shows that it's a working ZOR function with a neural network. So yeah, overall,
this is obviously a very simplified neural network, but it does have all of the fundamentals
that even complex neural networks have, i.e. you have weights, you have inputs, you have
multiplication of weights with activations, you have summations of those activations,
and then you have nonlinear activation functions. So obviously, most of the time people are using
Ray-Lew, you know, that function or that function. But this would be a threshold-based nonlinear
activation function instead. And of course, you know, this is still a very simple neural network,
but the idea it showed with this very early result from like the 1960s was that a single layer
network cannot represent ZOR, but a multi layer network can. And so deeper and deeper networks
can represent more and more complex functions over time. Okay. All right. Yes.
Yeah, a single layer perceptron would be unable to implement the ZOR function. Yeah. Yep.
So yeah. All right. Okay. Now, another sort of simple or well, maybe not that simple, but another
problem related to neural networks, specifically training neural networks. So this is sort of a
funny idea, but suppose you have a training set that contains only a single example repeated
100 times already. This is a very bad training set. But now we're going to also make it even
worse, say that 80 out of the 100 samples, you put a value of one as the label on it. And on the
other 20, you put a value of zero as the label on it. So obviously, this network's not like learning
any trend based on the data. It's all the outputs are totally arbitrary. But regardless of what kind
of network you had, say you are optimizing this network through back propagation. And so you
gradually update it and tell you reach a global optimum. What would the back propagation network
eventually predict for this example, assuming that it has been trained until it reaches a global
optimum. And the hint is to find the global optimum, differentiate the error function and set it
to zero. So this is, it's time for some calculus, calculus. So to break it down, intuitively, the data
suggests that a probabilistic prediction, probably of output equals one equals 0.8 is appropriate.
And the network will adjust its weights to minimize the error function. So the error function,
in this case, you're using the squared error summation, one half summation over i, the samples
of yi, the ground truth, minus ai, the predicted value, a squared error. And so if you're optimizing
the network to minimize this error, you would want to essentially, you would compute what the
minimum of this error function is by looking for a local minimum with the calculus. But if we expand
this function, we know that 80 of the samples will have yi equal to one. So we have an 80 here and
we have a one here. And 20 of the samples will have yi equal to zero. So we have 20 here and zero
here. And so we can do the products and we can expand this and reduce the terms. And at the end,
we have a quadratic expression, 50 a1 squared minus 80 a1 plus 40. And then if you took the
derivative of this with respect to a1, you would get through, you know, low bill calculus, 100 a1
minus 80. And if you set this equal to zero and solve for the value of a, you would indeed find
that you get a1 equals zero point eight. So, yes. I'm not sure if you'll need to know exactly
this, but I don't know. I am not sure. I do not know. Sorry. I personally have not seen what
the final exam looks like at this time, so I'm not sure. Again, I'm not, I'm not sure. Sorry.
Okay. Well, anyway, so that finishes section 18 that just leaves the last section. We'll talk
about section 22, which is on reinforcement learning. And I'll just give you a heads up that,
these, a lot of these questions are more conceptual. The sample problems for this section,
there weren't as many like numerical ones. So these are like more conceptual problems about RL.
So this first one, 21.2, chapter 17 defined a proper policy for an MDP Markov decision process,
as one that is guaranteed to reach a terminal state, show that it is possible for a passive ADP
agents to learn a transition model for which its policy pie is improper, even if pie is proper
for the true MDP. So as with such models, the policy evaluation step may fail if gamma equals one,
show that this problem cannot arise if policy evaluation is applied to the learned model only at
the end of a trial. So yeah, so this is a bit of a wordy problem, but it boils down to a proof
by example, essentially. So they say, consider a world with two states, S0 and S1, with two actions
in each state either state still or move to the other state. Assume the move action is non-deterministic
and it may sometimes fail, leaving the agent in the same state. Furthermore, assume that the agent
starts in S0 and that S1 is a terminal state, so a simple two-state world. So then if the agent
tries several move actions and they all fail because of bad luck, random chance, the agent may
conclude that the transition T of S0 move S1 is zero, and thus it may choose a policy where pie
of S0 equals stay, which is an improper policy. And so if we instead wait until the agent reaches S1
before updating the policy, we won't fall victim to this problem. So yeah, just an interesting
example, I suppose. Okay, then 21.8 grid world. This question asks, devise suitable features
for reinforcement learning in stochastic grid world, generalizations of the four by three world
that contain multiple obstacles and multiple terminal states with rewards of plus one or minus one.
So this is just, this is again an open-ended question. So it's just about proposing features that
could be useful for the agent to have access to or to see. Does anyone want to propose any features
that might be useful? I think there's things like what's the distance to the nearest plus one
is an example. What's the distance to the nearest minus one terminal state?
Things like what's the distance to the nearest obstacle or how many obstacles are nearby?
Basically, this is just a, this would be like an open format question. So you could propose a lot
of different options, but the examples that they gave were things like distance to the nearest
plus one or minus one terminal state, number of adjacent plus one or minus one terminal states,
number of adjacent obstacles, number of obstacles that intersect with a path to the nearest
plus one terminal state, for example. Okay, and then the last question, this one, 21.13 evolution
as RL, this is again another more conceptual problem. I'm not really sure if you would have,
I don't think you would really have questions like this that are more conceptually oriented because
I'm not sure how you would put it. This is a multiple-choice question, but this is just a question
from the book that talked about, you know, what are the parallels between reinforcement learning
and and evolution and what kind of connections exist or what kind of things are different.
And so some things are like, what are the analogs between the reward signal, the learning process
or the policy? You could imagine a simple animal that doesn't learn in its lifetime,
and its behavior is fully determined by its genotype, which would be like the parameters of its
policy, but then mutations and crossovers can create new values for the parameters,
but then you'd also could imagine as a reinforcement learning process that works on many different
copies of Pi simultaneously. However, a complication of this is that each copy of Pi
modifies the environment for other copies, whereas RL, the environment is fixed. And then they
talk about the reward function, like they say that RL maximizes the sum of rewards, whereas in
biology, you're trying to maximize reproductive fitness. So in this view, evolution could be viewed
as trying to find Pi that generates the most copies of itself over time, but there's more complexity
to that. There's multiple genes that contribute to a genotype and influence things in different
ways. There's complexity of multi-agent environments, and also maybe most important organisms learned
during their lifetime. They're not just derived fully from their genotype. So overall, they say that
from a philosophical perspective, one must be careful not to assume an absolute equivalence
between the two, but instead view parallel similarities and differences when drawing these kinds of
comparisons. So overall, that's more of a conceptual problem that they included. But
with that, that was the last of the sample problems I pulled. Overall, there are more sample problems
that can be found at aimacode.github.io slash aimaxercises. Yeah, are there any questions?
So I will tell you that let me just double check. Bill and Sujong sent me their list of sample
problems which came from sections 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, and 22. Oh, oh wait. Not 22, 21. That was a
typo. It should be 2021. That's the reinforcement learning section. In the aimacode, some of the numbers
changed. So 22 became NLP instead of RL. So that would be 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, and 21 would be all
the sections. I think that would be relevant. Overall, though, I would suggest review the course
slides to make sure just to verify that it matches up with the subject material that you've been
learning about. But yeah, all right. Well, are there any other questions?
All right. Well, in that case, I wish you all good luck. Break a leg with the final exam.
That exam, I think, is about a week from today. If I'm mistaken.
December 17, I think. Yes.
I'm going to assume, probably, yes. If you're not, if you want, post about it on Piazza,
but I'm going to assume that this exam should be basically conducted with the same format as
the other two midterms, essentially. So yeah.
All right. Well, in that case, thank you all for coming.